president biden has a big problem when
it comes to the truth about getting out
of afghanistan top generals testifying
today on capitol hill and directly
contradicting a key claim made by the
commander-in-chief
all three military leaders say they
warned biden to leave thousands of
troops in the country to avoid a
catastrophe but he didn't listen and
then he claimed it didn't happen
i recommended that we maintain 2500
troops in afghanistan my assessment was
uh
back in the fall of 20 and it remained
consistent throughout that we should
keep a steady state of 2500 and it could
bounce up to 3 500 maybe something like
that their input was
was received by the president and
considered by the president so no no one
told your military advisor did not tell
you no we should just keep 2500 troops
it's been a stable situation for the
last several years we can do that we can
continue to do that no no one said that
to me that i can recall
and while president biden's calling how
we left afghanistan a quote
extraordinary success general milley
says the rest of the world doesn't see
it that way
i think that our credibility um with
allies and partners around the world and
with adversaries
is being intensely reviewed by them to
see which way this is going to go
and i think that damage is one word that
could be used
and what about accountability if you
think at least some heads should roll
for this fiasco think again
senator
as a senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing it's
a political act if i'm resigning in
protest he doesn't have to make those
decisions uh just because we're generals
and it would be an incredible
act of political defiance for a
commissioned officer to just resign
because my advice is not taken
so the big thing we learned today dana
obviously among other things biden was
told by all the military leaders just
leave a few thousand guys in there to
make sure it's calm he ignored them and
then told the american people a lie
about what he was recommended i remember
when he did that interview with george
stephanopoulos and he said um nobody
told me that and he said not that i
recall right and i thought okay well
one we know that's not going to be true
because we've been seen for months even
during the trump administration that the
military was suggesting leaving a small
force there and that was increasingly so
in the spring of la of this year april
of 2021 as this decision was being made
i think the president made it in april
right before the beginning of april
2021. and i thought well they better
hope that that turns out to be true but
of course it didn't and i thought that
was the big headline that came out of
today is that
he that now it's okay
if a commander-in-chief wants to
get briefed and then go in a different
direction and make a different decision
he's the decider but what he did is say
i made a decision but it was based on
not on something that they told me and
now they're contradicting them and i
wouldn't have wanted necessarily to be
in their shoes today right because
they're having to defend a failure
that they know
was partly because biden didn't take
their advice
and they don't want to completely throw
the commander-in-chief under the bus
but then this other piece when senator
inhofe
had millie say that basically we have no
counterterrorism on the ground
also milli said it was a logistical
success but a strategic failure
i think it's hard to spend leaving
americans behind and interpreters and
all of our helpers behind as a
logistical success i understand that
they got a lot of people out but again
who were the people that they got out
they weren't the people that we were
supposed to help right and milly we also
learned is a huge leaker dan and he is
talking to everybody in the media all of
these authors here's senator marcia
blackburn asking what general georgia
seth milley has been doing this whole
time instead of planning the afghan
withdrawal he's been talking to about a
half dozen reporters listen
general millie
um
yes or no to this did you talk to bob
woodard or robert costa for their book
peril
woodward yes cost or no did you talk to
carol leonik and philip rucker for their
book alone can i fix it yes did you talk
to michael bender for his book book is
frankly we did win this election the
inside story of how trump lost yes yes
and were you accurately represented in
these books i haven't read any of the
books
so i don't know
you buying that dan
i mean
really come on guy he didn't read the
book so he spent all this time talking
to me this is look milly looks to me
like the kind of guy not only reads the
books but like frames them and puts them
on the wall like for everyone to read
but he said a couple things there were a
couple of really stunning moments there
holly caught him pretty good when uh hit
well that was austin but hearing when
they got them to acknowledge it you guys
left americans behind like just cut the
crap like there are americans there
right now like just stop saying you
didn't leave americans behind you did
admit it
apologize profusely for it get them out
and do your thing but millie did
something in the hearing a lot of people
didn't catch it i don't know how they
missed it here he said to entirely
contradictory things he's talking about
the call to china which he claims now
has been misrepresented we'll see where
he spoke to the chinese communist party
and usurped the role of the
commander-in-chief and basically said i
was there to defuse a situation so we
didn't misinterpret anything that's not
his job i mean if the
commander-in-chief's role is to be
strategically misinterpreted that's a
strategy i mean you may not like it but
it's not millie's job but then later on
did you catch it so he's in the
decision-making chain there and he's
like no big deal later on when asked
about the decision to withdraw from
bagram he totally passes the buck i'm
not a decision maker folks i'm just a
conduit so what is it general are you a
conduit or are you a decision maker
i'm surprised nobody caught that i
talked about it on my radio show he had
two contradictory things and another
contradiction he said that he doesn't
talk to
anybody about conversations he has with
the president that's how he got out of
all answering questions today yet he
told bob ward every conversation he had
with donald trump so let's just go to
this other stuff i mean there's a lot of
finger-pointing military's pointing at
state departments state department
points at the afghan army
military points at the white house no
one's accountable but they want a
bipartisan commission in a few years
what do you think is going to happen
there
i think it will be quite important i
think the american public is happy
actually to see the people who were
advising the president on this decision
that everyone agrees with the intent but
doesn't agree with the execution to see
what they actually said or not because
we all saw the stephanopoulos interview
and so we thought that president biden
had been on the same page with the
people who would know better and were
actually reading the intelligence on the
ground so i actually don't see
these particular ones as wasted hearings
whereas i usually do and i see them as
kind of grandstanding and everyone just
trying to get in their cable news well
the one thing that did come out of it as
you mentioned that was productive
they're going to have a written
recommendation that the brass delivered
to the white house and it was in writing
and they've asked for that so once they
get that in their hands that's pretty
explosive it certainly could be we'll
wait to see what it is and i would
remind everyone at the table not that
you've necessarily forgotten in the
audience that bob menendez a democrat
and a strong ally of president bidens
has been the one leading the charge on
trying to get this information um to
dana's point about milli saying
logistical success strategic failure
i think that what he was trying to
convey was how dire the circumstances
were when biden said we are leaving in
like two weeks and so what can you get
done in that amount of time i thought
that to dan's point about the call with
china uh the reason that he wasn't
actually usurping the
commander-in-chief's power is because
mark esper
told him to do it and was behind the
decision that's the january call not the
january october because the giant you're
talking about two separate calls those
are the channels
the china those are two separate calls
there's an october i think there was a
november october call and then the
january the one where he also went back
to yeah miller acting secretary miller
has already said we did not authorize
the call they're two separate calls you
may be right about but not the second
one they asked for one i know that he
was following the chain of command and
that's that's even in the woodward rook
too
john rich your thoughts about today's
hearing well there's an interesting
hypocrisy going on right now we all know
the story of the young service man who
went on facebook and called out his
superiors he called out millie he called
out all of them and said what are you
doing apologize tell us why you made
this horrific mistake and he's in the
brig today yeah he's in the brig and so
what you just saw in this hearing is you
saw the most powerful generals in our
country effectively calling out biden
saying no no no we told him to do this
but he did that and we don't know why is
that not effectively calling out the
president united states they're not in
the brig they've still got their jobs
but the young man who called them out is
now in handcuffs so i don't understand
the duplicitous nature of that but i
don't like it no one likes it and maybe
one of the reporters one day if they get
a chance can ask joe biden
you saw the hearing mr president not a
lot of agreement there you lied to the
american people any response to that
maybe peter ducey our very own our very
own peter ducey there's another hearing
tomorrow on the house side i expect a
little bit more
fire yeah yeah all right dana will be
covering it i'm sure hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else